[Music]
vance is in wilmington north carolina hi
vance welcome to the show how can we
help
good day gentlemen um
biggest issue i guess is budget staying
on track um
you know i make 56 000 a year currently
um i unfortunately lost my job at the
beginning of the year
um and had to sacrifice you know for
less money per year
and you know as of right now it just
seems like a vicious circle
um get paid then i am basically
paid most of my paycheck and credit card
payments
just to be broke before we get to my
next paycheck and have to put it all
right back on credit cards
how much credit card debt have you got
right now it's not the um
eight thousand okay and how much do you
know how much you know in your car
um we have the van we got because of
so many kids is 16 000.
okay what else um
outside i only owe 1400 left on my
student loans
um our home in wilmington has actually
paid off um what's it worth
tax value is about 148. how many kids
um five children what ages
um the oldest is
29 six and four
so you're not feeding the 29 year old no
no no they're out of the house it's you
know it's incidentals you know
they're pretty much self-sufficient you
know it's just uh incidental to them
they either are or they're not they're
not pretty much
well you know you get the occasional
call of um
you're broke so when they call
just go i'm broke
so i can help with that let's cut off
the incidentals to the
uh grown kiddos all right now then
the other thing that's going on is this
um you guys are i can tell anthony and
you can tell too
there is not a written detailed plan
here absolutely not
okay that's what thousands yeah and this
we've tried and it's always gone way far
left field yeah you know and it never
thought up again
well you didn't try hard enough because
yeah so i think the problem here is not
really the money problem
uh because um you're making fifty eight
thousand dollars
yeah we need to make more money but we
know people who are making 35 40 000
and they're budgeting living below their
means and they're they're making things
happen
um so right now you have to get on the
plan
and uh and i can say this respectfully
but straightforward you have to stop
saying exactly and just do it
yeah the the thing is the um
what what i need the way to approach the
budget differently and this should help
you vance
is um you're not writing up a template
for the perfect month from heaven
because that never occurs right
instead you are saying november
starts sunday so you have homework
between now and sunday you and your wife
put the kids that live at home to bed
yeah turn off the stupid freaking
television there you go
and get you could just get out of yellow
pad if you want or you can jump on every
dollar and download the app for free
but what you're trying to do here is
you're going to say okay what income
will i have take home pay how many
checks have i got coming in in november
and what are the dates
and that's your income and then you give
every one of those dollars a name in
order of importance
so the first thing on your list i'll
help you with this is food
and i'm not talking about eating out
because you're broke you're not eating
out
i'm talking about groceries for cooking
from scratch
at home okay food
you know what the next one is lights and
water
you know what the next one is shelter
how much is your house payment
um right now the only thing we have to
pay now is oh it's paid off
insurance and taxes right and so shelter
yes sir so we're taking care of basic
necessities so if you've taken care of
food shelter clothing transportation you
pay the car payment you put gas in the
car
and this is all written out as an exact
game plan
you've still got a lot of money left
after you do those things
in your monthly budget and you're going
to go where's my money been going
right that's what anthony are doing and
i are doing looking at your numbers
we're going
where's the guy's money going this is
how we it's easy for us to presuppose
you're not doing a detailed
written game plan if you will do that
and spend november's income
on november's bills exactly and then
whatever you write down is what happens
nothing else
get the stupid credit cards out and have
a plastic surgery party
yeah chop those puppies little bitty
pieces
as a matter of fact if you have firearms
go ahead and put them out in the
backyard get
violent with them put some 45 caliber
holes in their butt
i mean do something where this is set up
where you are
viscerally remembering the day the
weekend
the year that sucked is the year we
turned it around
november 2020 baby that was our year and
you drive a stake in the ground
emotionally and you say never again i'm
not living like this i can tell you when
we did
it we went bankrupt absolutely when i
went homeless that's when i did it
yeah so when you get sick and tired of
being sick and tired
you'll do whatever it takes yeah so the
written game plan
start this weekend and we'll put you and
your wife into ramsay plus so you can go
through financial peace university
and so you can get the premium version
of every dollar
and at the baby steps tracker we are
experts on leading you through this
process
but to anthony's earlier point you've
got to really do it
yeah yeah and you got to have enough
thing
because you're really not stuck your
math is not stuck
you're disorganized it's chaos you got
to spend
and then you get to the end of the month
and you ain't gain money and you know
and that's what you know what that is
that's
normal yeah that's a normal person yeah
and you god
god knows normal sucks you don't want to
be normal
and i don't want to pick on him i
wouldn't say this to everyone
but i'm just saying i think when i hear
people say i make this a kind of money
but when i get my paycheck oh i spend it
all over here i go
well this is what i hear dave lack of
discipline you don't have a plan
yeah there's there's no plan there's no
discipline sit here even tell yourself
no this is what we're going to do we're
going to get on the budget we're going
to stick to this budget
and we're going to get out of debt write
it down go over it with your spouse so
both of you look at it you pinky
swearing spit shake this a freaking
contract yes
you're not allowed to do anything else
with money yeah because this one worked
when you put it down on paper
right then if you don't live it exactly
that way then it won't work
it won't work and you go well you know
we were tired from working so we went
out to eat
i'll kiss my butt you cannot do that
stuff
i mean you just you cannot wash out yeah
but i mean in our culture today
the idea of going without restaurant
food for an entire
six month period of time people think
we'll die
it'll be over my whole life will be over
because
it's a it's such a form of entertainment
but you know what to dave you can talk
to this i can't
it's it's even harder to tell your kids
no i can't help you
you know it wasn't for us because our
kid number one our kids are little and
number two we're like
old-fashioned parents we actually think
we're in charge
and so no is a complete sentence i don't
need to give you a further explanation i
i own you and i can make another one
looks just like you so
i mean we're old school we were old
school and sharon's worse than i am i
mean she's a
hillbilly mother man i mean it's just
like knock you on your noggin you're
going to do it and
you know stop your whining we're not
going out to eat why not
we'd leave church when they were little
rachel will be in the back seat yakking
you know rachel was tracking
yeah she could talk she can talk man and
uh
she'd be going i want a guy and we're
going we're going to we're going to the
nicest restaurant
in america where is that sharon's
restaurant
they got where they hated don't tell us
sharon's restaurant don't don't tease us
and tell us we're going to eat and we're
going to sharon's restaurant oh but she
does cook better than any restaurant
anyway to start with
yeah it's not like they were getting
microwave crap or something they
actually actually woman actually cooks
and so you know i mean it's amazing and
that's
that you know that's how rachel grew up
yeah that's good and then
when you did get to go to a restaurant
it was an event
it was a big deal later on and so you
had more of a tendency to behave while
you were in the restaurant absolutely
because it was an actual privilege
rather than an entitlement well that's
good dave at least you have a wife that
cooks pray for mika this generation
don't know how to cook
man they have these neat things called
recipes yes
recipe book it's just follow the
directions that's it even i can do that
crap
i could do that too